so you were in ottawa you finished your
degree you're doing massage therapy
you're now fairly bilingual now i'm
fairly bilingual and jordan gives me a
call
when was the last time you talked to him
i
used to see him at christmas you know
i'd come home at christmas
every year and then i didn't for a
couple of years and
then he said he was going to move to
ottawa and i thought oh that'd be nice
and then he didn't he got a job in
edmonton so he
didn't come so then i kind of thought
well i'm just going to pick up my life
and
and go forward yeah so i i went out with
a fellow and lived with him for a couple
of years
and then i was finishing my degree and i
got a phone call from jord that he was
in montreal
that he was doing his phd and he was
going to mcgill and so i went there
for thanksgiving 1986
and he looked like he was doing all
right and he was a lot taller well he
was a lot taller a year after high
school
i met him in fairview he got out of his
car and he got out of his car for
like a second or two longer than usual
because he wasn't a foot dollar
he still wasn't marriable at that point
though he was pretty much a wild man at
that point
but once i got to mcgill he looked like
he wasn't quite as much of a wild man
and that he was getting a life and that
he had a plan
and i thought that it was a part there
was a possibility that maybe we could
make a go of it because he had already
asked me to marry him a couple of times
by then
when at christmas at new year's
i think at new year's i said yes that
was the last time what
i don't remember hearing about this i
thought he wrote it to you in a letter
he did he wrote me a letter and and
asked me to marry him there and i
thought is this guy
for real yeah kind of something that's
not very romantic where's the knee
and the ring yeah it's like well we did
live 3000 miles apart
yeah and that you know back then to call
home was uh
it wasn't you didn't have a cell phone
you didn't have a cell phone plan or
anything
it it's kind of money for a long long
distance
and we didn't have it i didn't have any
extra money neither did he yeah
and it is kind of romantic yeah he wrote
me i think that used to be the way
it was people would write letters i
imagine yeah
a lot of letter writing you know love
letters remember you've heard of
yeah yeah yeah so he wrote me i think he
was probably going to europe
and wanted to know if i wanted to get go
with him and also get married but i
thought maybe he was joking because it
was written in kind of a joking way
he's totally nervous yeah he could pass
it off as a joke if you said no
just in case that's right so i didn't
quite know how to take it so
i just kind of left that there and one
time he asked me and i said maybe
i wasn't ready yet i didn't want to say
no but i wasn't ready to say yes
i still had to see which way his life
well when we got married i was 27.
so did he ask you the first time when
you're like 25 or something oh maybe 23.
oh okay that's pretty young that's
pretty young yeah
i didn't know that oh yeah yeah you know
it started like that early like the
asking the asking
yeah the asking started kind of early
you just tortured him for like
four years yeah when he started to it
looked like he was gonna start to have
some girlfriends
i married him as soon as you saw other
women moving in that's funny yeah
he was and he was just starting to feel
like confident and everything and then i
married him